[inaudible].
You're listening to radiolab from New York public radio, public radio, W,
Y, Y, c, n, n,
p. R.
[inaudible].
If you want your animals Frisky, you'll start as early as possible.
Today's show is about animals and at six o'clock there would be crowds of people
flowing, pushing each other all over the way, jostling, laughing,
streaming towards the venue about people getting close to animals.
You have hundreds of lions and panthers, Cheetahs. You have the baboon.
You had an Indian, right? [inaudible] about what happens when we bring animals
into power world. The slaughter is unimaginable.
[inaudible]
if there was more over the crowd,
there is musical instruments rolling everybody up.
That's Marina Belarus. Skyah.
She's a historian and what she's describing is route 80 80 if you are lucky
enough to be alive then and get a seat at the Roman coliseum on a good day,
you could watch no joke. Hundreds. Yeah.
The animals slaughtered right in front of your eyes, one after the other.
All kinds of exotic creatures. The populous never knew what would take place.
That was part of the agitation. They wanted the suspense.
They wanted the tension.
Great. So now that you have that picture in your mind, consider this one.
Bye.
Wow.
Here we are at the Bronx Zoo, the gorilla exhibit and what you've got her in.
Well, no blood, no cheap thrills,
just kids with a baby on the bed like a piggyback ride.
Lots of kids smushing their faces to the glass,
trying to get the attention of the gorillas on the other side.
Real is aren't really noticing. But then, and this is the big moment,
one of the dumped gorillas turns around,
walks to its side of the glass and down
[inaudible] his hand on the wall.
[inaudible]
today on radio lab. We wonder how did we get here? I mean throughout history,
even before Rome, I relationship to animals is pretty simple. Okay?
We brutalized them. That's how it worked. Then in the 19th century,
someone created the zoological garden,
which wasn't much better and now we've got the zoo and we still lord over the
animals, but now we want to be their friends. We want to help them.
How did that happen and how exactly do you help an animal?
And this is an honest question when it has to spend its entire life in a cage
today on radio lab, zoos are our topic. I'm Jad Abumrad well, you know,
I think I can take you to the very moment in modern zoo history when the balance
kind of shifted in. Who are you? Oh,
I'm Robert Krulwich and I love the zoo, but don't wait.
You don't know about the zoo? Kind of me icky.
Why? I just, I, I want the animals to not be there.
And then gave you somebody what's prettier, safer, safer, prettier.
I'd rather watch them on TV frankly, and let them let them,
well, the guy, this is interesting.
The guy who made the big move in modern zoo history. No. Hello. That's him.
Hello. His name is David Hancocks. We got him into a studio and he sort of,
he sorted a little bit like you. He was very ambivalent about zoos.
I'd actually for a while toyed with the idea of do I want to go and work in zoos
and try to change them or do I want to stay outside zoos and work to close them
down and I came to conclusion that there's no way you're going to close who's
down that the fascination of wanting to be close to wild animals cuts across
every strata of society. This is my case, by the way.
I love being close to them. Anyway, David Hancock's decided if,
if you can't beat them, you join them. Man.
It was in the mid 1970s and David was working actually as an architect.
He was between jobs when he got a call.
A friend recommended him for a job at the woodland park zoo in Seattle. Yes,
yes. And he gets hired.
I was in an unusually fortunate situation in that just after I was hired and got
there, the zoo director left and so there was nobody to run the place.
Well except for David.
So he decided to take a look at the entire philosophy of the zoo and change
everything. Starting with the gorillas.
They leave
awful cages. The,
the gorillas were living in a small concrete building.
It was a spare empty concrete box with a glass window. The gorillas,
of course, were bored and slowly going out of their mind.
Occasionally you'd find a gorilla who'd take his feces and smear it on the wall.
Yes, I'm going. I had nothing else to interact with.
The only natural components in his life that he ever came into contact with
would have been the food that he ate and the feces that he produced.
Cages were the problem. The solution. He decided, well,
he wanted to rip up the cages, yanked them out completely,
and replaced them with, with something, a natural setting of some sort.
But when he looked around for a model,
no zoo in the world had gorillas in what you'd call a natural setting.
And he wasn't even sure what is natural for, say, a gorilla. There
was very, very little known about gorillas and their wild behavior.
In fact, all the books said that gorillas don't claim,
this was early in the 70s remember? So David invited a person who didn't know.
I heard about Diane Fossey. Diane's fast,
his work was beginning to be carried in national geographic or Diane Fossey and
yeah, from the, from that Sigourney weaver movie, she played the [inaudible],
she was played by Sigourney weaver. Diane Fossey was an actual person.
She lived with a group of gorillas, wrote down everything.
She saw all their social interactions and all and was, um,
the guerrilla expert at that time.
And I heard that she was coming to the u s and she agreed to come to Seattle and
spend a couple of days with us.
We were trying to get images from her of the sort of environment we could
create.
And the breakthrough came after the couple of days she'd spent with that.
So I was driving her back to the airport and I said,
is there anything you seen around here or anywhere in this part of the world
that in any way resembles the sort of places where you've seen gorillas in the
wild? And she just pointed to this verge on the freeway. Um,
I don't know what a verge is. What's a verge avert? Oh, sorry. You were the,
the landscape on the side of the freeway, they're sloping at what,
what would you call it? I would call it if they were President Kennedy,
I would call it a a not a, what do they call it and no, yes and no,
but I wouldn't call it that because only president Kennedy gets out,
I would call it the, the green stuff on the side of the road. Okay. Yep.
It was a banked area that had once been cleared and then this verdant growth
that you get in Seattle was springing back and she said that right there,
that's where I would expect to see,
to be observing gorillas in the wild till I dropped her at the airport,
came back and on the way back illegally parked on the side of the freeway and
took photographs and then said, here, this is what day and fast. He said,
so as you can tell, we have absolutely no idea what they were doing,
but they also didn't have a boss and within a few months with help from a
landscape architect, I am grant Jones from Seattle, Washington.
He drew up a plan and elk came the balloons
exactly,
and we were creating huge mountains and hills about 10 or 15 feet high.
Some rocky cliffs along one side creek off trees,
shrubs about three or four feet high,
big herbs and vegetables and angles of vines, undergrowth,
lots of Laurel Bushes, Hawthorne Trees,
they comfrey leaves that we planted have long berries and pointed drip tips,
tropical likeliest growing pioneer plants. Just let it grow wild.
Now nobody was watching,
nobody was watching us and that that was the critical factor I think. Yes,
because if a traditional zoo director had seen or heard what we were doing,
they would, he would have stopped it and why?
Why would a traditional zookeeper have have stopped all because they were
worried about what would like,
suppose you had been a gorilla and you'd spend your whole life living in a cage
in a concrete cage and now I'm going to take you little jam my baby gorilla and
stick him into a completely new place with sky and jagged things.
I mean, I would be worried that you'd hurt yourself.
I in the zoo world generally, I think
people were very nervous about it. That's violet Sunday.
She was the gorilla keeper at the Seattle's. Yes.
I was their primary keeper at that time and the zoo was advised by a lot of zoo
experts that it wouldn't work. I had two directors tell me it was stupid,
irresponsible, and it was unnecessarily, yeah. You know,
the gorillas would follow the trees and hurt themselves as climbed.
They would fall and break their necks on break their bones or they didn't get to
putting their health at risk and diseases.
They would get sick because it wasn't a sterile environment where you could,
you know, disinfect concrete to get psychologically.
Do you range from all this space? Yes.
Sometimes I'd go to David Hancock's then say,
what are we going to do about these people? He'd say, ignore them.
A bold statement,
but as the clock tick down to the day that these five animals would walk from
their iron cage through a door into this field.
Yeah.
It was a real open question at the time. Well, what will happen? I think,
I think we were all somewhat nervous. We were nervous. Oh sure.
How will they react? What will they do? The truth is nobody knew
[inaudible]
and so after five years getting ready after 16,000 square feet of guerrilla
display area, we're prepared. Finally,
it was time on this sunny July, I think most, I remember it was a July morning.
I remember the exact year. I think it's seventies actually. I just looked it up.
Uh, July 31st, 1979, um, we let them out.
Kiki was the first two to come to that doorway and look out Kiki was it the
dominant gorilla of this group? There was six gorillas. He was the star.
I think he was my favorite. I have to confess,
he was so smart and he was big. He was six feet tall,
460 pounds. Kiki came into view first.
And of course she's never seen anything remotely like this before.
So here he is, this huge creature standing at the doorway,
just looking at this unknown.
You stood in the doorway for many minutes
and finally Kiki's starts to slowly step forward
first step.
And he went as far as a creek and sat down,
do any looked up.
We noticed he looked up for a long time and we looked up also,
clouds were blowing by med,
fairly low altitude swallows flying over here. They were crows in the trees.
There was a wind blowing, the trees were rustling, the grass was moving.
You could see the hair on his face moving
[inaudible]
[inaudible] for a long time and took all this in.
And then he looked down into the end of the water in a little eddy there any,
you could see that he was looking at his face in the water,
which she'd never seen.
And then he just starts looking all around and then all of a sudden he sees us
grant violet and David and a few others were standing behind some glass at an
observation point.
They were about a hundred yards away from the doorway.
And he came right up to the glass where we were at.
They knew that Kiki had been a pretty angry to reel before and then he did
something that, um, we in a million years, hoped he never would,
which was to reach down into the sands,
screwed his arm down deep into the sand and he pulls out this big chunk of
broken concrete about six, eight inches wide.
And then he held it up over his head. We thought, oh, this is it.
He's going to break the windows.
We'd spent weeks raking and telling the contractor to remove all debris and
begging them to check and recheck to look for such things as this piece of
concrete. And there it was.
So Kiki held it over his head and sorta waved it around a little bit and looked
with an angry look. Yeah, this, he just held it there.
[inaudible]
then he just dropped it. He almost threw it down.
He just sort of dropped it down. We all breathe a sigh of relief.
And um,
then he laid down on his back and his mate Nina came over and sat beside him and
the little baby,
a little baby came over and laid on his chest and they just proceeded to,
uh, enjoy themselves. Like, like we weren't there.
It was magic.
It was just, it was magic.
They looked like different animals, totally different animals.
I felt like we were seeing a gorilla in the wild. Needless to say,
we all cried after he came over. I didn't cry. No. Um, but,
uh, I had a lump in my throat. I felt like finally, this is right.
This is really what's right for them.
I remember there was this strange feeling after it.
It's almost like we'd been to a wedding where there was this mixture of
happiness and sadness and I think more than anything else,
that was just a great sense
relief. We thought, well,
when will he produce this angry behavior and pound on the glass? And you know,
he never ever did it. The Old Kiki never returned,
never filled his body again. He was never angry anymore.
Well, I think what he's saying is that the Kiki had really changed the change in
cages, truly changed the animal here.
This is an interesting science question to, to, to ask about that.
It's like if you do that,
if you take an animal and put them into a radically different environment,
how exactly does that change the animal who
ms clearly makes them feel better and can you measure that? I think,
I think the closest we've come to an answer to that question is a little bit of
gold is actually done a test with primates where she's put them in different
types of enriched environments. That's Jonah Lehrer.
He's a science writer and regular radio lab contributor and what he's talking
about is a Princeton experiment. A group of scientists led by Elizabeth Gould,
took three groups of monkeys and put them into three different kinds of cages,
sort of like a classes and then the social classes that she divided them into a
middle, lower, a middle and an upper. Then we can go through each one.
Let's start at the top. One group of primates,
group a was in the Beverly hills of cages. Describe it.
Lots of different monkeys running around. They had lots of social interaction.
They had to forge for all their food, lots of toys. What kind of toys? You know,
squeezy toys or, or like balls. I really had, it doesn't matter.
So they had lots of choices to make. Lots of things to be engaged with.
Lots of conversations to have lots of stuff to occupy their mind.
And what about Group B? The middle-class Group B had, you know,
we'll call it like the uh, like the standard suburban setup.
Not too fancy that drove a Chevy. What? What are we really talking about here?
They just had a bit less of everything that a few less toys,
a few less monkeys in this granted enclosure. So we can say that,
that they had less. Yeah,
they had less than the third group was kind of these standard experiments on
closure, you know, wire cage. So they had a lot less. Yeah.
All right, so you've got these three classes of monkeys, upper, middle,
lower Gould, and her team put a bunch of monkeys in each class,
let them do their thing for a while,
and then they took a few of individuals from each of these groups and looked at
their brains. So,
so they looked at the amount of proteins you have in your synapses.
They looked at the density of your dendritic Arbors, which, which,
which is you just say dendritic arbors. Yeah, that's right. That's a great name.
They, they, they look botanical. Especially when they're happy.
There's little like each brain,
so branches out in all kinds of different directions when it's happy.
So you get kind of a bushy kind of a feel. Yeah, exactly. What does that mean?
If I'm an animal that good? Yeah, they think it is. I mean,
you can't exactly ask them monkey or gorilla, are you happy?
You could do no k in that cage, but you can look at their brain cells and ask,
are they branching,
are they growing and making new connections and getting full and bushy.
That's what these scientists wanted to know.
Which of the class of monkeys had the bushy is brain cells because those monkeys
would be the ones that are most engaged with their world most alive.
Okay, Jonah. So jumping forward, Elizabeth Gould looks into the brains of,
of individuals from each of the three classes. And what did she find?
She found that there's a big difference between the impoverished in the middle
class. Big Difference between the pot, between the bottom and the middle. Yeah.
The bottom, the middle is a big difference. How big it's, it's very significant.
It was generally between 20% and 40% 40% bushy or brain.
Yeah. Wow.
So what about the difference between the upper and the middle?
What was the difference there? There was almost no difference. What?
No difference at all. That's the weird thing between the lower and the middle.
Huge difference. Huge. But between the middle and the upper,
they really couldn't find much.
Mm.
Why will I buy?
I think the lesson is at a certain point it tipping point is reached and your
brain says, okay, we're in a complex world here. We have enough toys,
we have enough social interactions. We've hit the tipping point,
let's go full throttle. It invest in new neurons and a nice complex brain.
[inaudible]
right. Let me ask you a question.
What if you're a zoo animal and you're living in a crappy wire cage and then
they move you to a nicer one?
What would happen to your brain then as she has she looked into that? Yeah.
And uh, she's found that within four weeks, four weeks, about a month,
the brain itself has changed.
It begins to flourish again.
And how long did it take you say four weeks lead moments? Just four weeks.
Imagine mentally like after a year? Yeah,
after just four weeks they saw significant changes in the basic architecture of
their brain.
So Robert,
just imagine Kiki now gorilla who's brain has been stunted by eight years of
living in this little concrete box.
Suddenly Kiki is thrust outside where the weather changes.
Birds Fly with the rain falls from the sky where trees sway when he climbs.
Suddenly Kiki has challenges.
Choices, right? And to think that after eight years of he stuck,
his brain could explode with new activity
in just four weeks. I mean, but that makes sense. You know, nature and nature,
it's respond quickly. They're not going in.
Most animals don't have four years to sit around and develop a complex brain.
Our neurons have to act fast.
The message from this research is clear from the perspective of the brain.
You can easily create a cage which allows the brain to flourish. You see,
I told, I told you that if you make the zoo better,
you can make the beasts better. This is built in. Zoos are not horrible, please.
No, no, no. I know. Yeah, they are. I think before we get ahead of ourselves,
okay. Let me just, let me just throw one more time. Keep that in mind. Yeah.
Let me just throw one more category into our little class hierarchy here.
Okay. The category of creatures who live in the wild,
no cages, so in a sense, this is like your lab. Yeah.
He's paid a visit to a guy named Fernando, not Bob.
I'm a biologist at Rockefeller University in New York, and that's where we are.
We're in the woods outside his lab,
which stretched for thousands of acres and he calls these woods is real loud.
It goes up to a chicken. That right there. Which one?
They're a little teeny guys, Huh? And in the trees
are his subjects.
What these birds do is in the fall they start hiding seeds or nuts throughout
the forest and they have to remember where they put them.
Winter will come on at some point, everything will be under a blanket of snow.
So if you remember where you hit the seeds, you'll be the survivor.
Because I mean, and the case of chickadees, whichever is small,
for them to be alive the next morning,
they'll have to go to sleep with a full belly.
Is that because their metabolism is so fast? The right, right.
I mean they're small birds. They lose heat like mad. It's a cold night.
It's long. It lasts 10 hours. I mean,
you got to sleep on an empty stomach the next morning you're dead.
Knowing this not bombed, didn't experiment.
He caught a bunch of wild chickadees divided them into two groups. First group,
he put in a cage, pretty big cage and by five by three or something like that.
Second group set free so they could roam the woods as they pleased over this
home range of about 30 acres. He did place bird fears throughout the woods,
so they'd come back and visit. Wintertime rolls around.
The wild chickadees are out there snatching seeds from the bird feeder and
hiding them everywhere like crocs or Barack or crackle stone or how many hiding
places are we talking about here? Probably talking about thousands.
It's a phenomenal memory task.
The cage chickadees meanwhile didn't have to remember anything cause they could
eat as many seeds as they wanted from a little trough in the cage,
not bombed at a brain comparison.
And what he found was in certain brain regions,
the wild chickadees had twice as many new neurons.
Birds as the case ones were recruiting twice as many new neurons as the old one,
twice, twice as many. You know,
that process of replacement was moving at a much brisker pace.
His theory is that these new neurons are always showing up every day,
like day laborers. The only question is,
is there a job for them in the wild group? Absolutely.
We need your help to remember where we put all those seeds in the cage group.
There's nothing for those neurons to do, but here's the sad part.
They still show up every single day.
This appeared over a few days over which I'm here and either gets a job or
doesn't, doesn't get a job, and he does. So just awesome. So yeah,
you don't get a job. You're gone. You don't have to kill yourself.
You're just not going to get what it takes to stay alive,
which makes it all the more poignant to me. I mean, in the captives,
you've got all these new cells, they're ready to do some work.
You might give them your job precisely that. I'd love to do it,
but it's a shrinking economy guy. So what can I do?
Mm mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm,
mm [inaudible].
Thanks to Fernando, not bum.
He's a biologist at Rockefeller University in upstate New York
[inaudible]
and also before him to science writer, Jonah Lehrer,
who is the author of the upcoming book. Proust was a neuroscientist
and coming up.
What does a ferocious meat eating 500 pound funeral cat eat for dinner at the
zoo. What? Uh, it's such a discipline. Yeah. Oh No,
I don't wanna I don't wanna tell Ya.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad you're Robert and will continue with our program on zoos zoo.
What an unusual [inaudible]. Don't you wonder like where it comes from?
We have to get, it used to be zoo one second.
It used to be called the zoological gardens and then it got this like short
name. Yeah. What is it? A song? Let me introduce you. This is it.
I believe Ms Lou in the 1878 song called walking,
walking in the Xer.
Well, keep him walking in.
People heard the song. They couldn't think of a place in any other way.
[inaudible]
hi, this is Lisa Beck calling from Fort Worth, Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
your which I'm just going to go. Yeah, just go do it. Ready? Yeah.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Today our topic is zoos. We're doing a little sort of chronological thing,
tracing the line from past to present,
starting back at those old nasty concrete enclosures,
which I'm sure you love to visit as a little
boy.
What do you mean? Well, you know you're a city boy, you, you,
you don't have much animals here. Nothing to do with New York.
What did like Tennessee [inaudible] fine,
but when you talk about, you know,
enriching the lives of gorillas as we did before the break.
It's a simple heartwarming story cause gorillas, a r s building,
they had their vegetarians rankling it gets a lot more complicated when you
switch to a Predator and who likes to pounce and chase and bite. Yes.
If you're going to put those animals in a cage and their whole being is
organized around killing things, well what do you feed them?
[inaudible] guys that question to a NPR science reporter. Now Boys,
if we're talking like the big carnivores,
like the Tigers that would normally be out in the wild ripping other animals to
shred. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. What do they eat? They're eating mostly this, uh,
this is a little bag of um, uh, kibble. It's,
it's basically like a dog food near and check it out because this is for a
meeting animal. [inaudible] oh, again, try one. Alright.
Skinny. Oh,
that's like getting chocked
here. This is what the predators eat according to now. Really?
Why don't they just give them meat? That's sort of what she wanted to know.
Testing the mini days before heading to the zoo.
Testing the many days before heading to the zoo. No,
recently took a trip to the Toledo zoo.
Oh, hi. I'm here to see Ann.
She wanted to know what it might look like if a zoo actually gave the predators
what they want in this regard. The Toledo zoo is pretty radical.
Once a year they have this event they call the big, the big
fee. Did the big Phoenix the opening. Thank you. No,
got there a day early just to check things out. Okay.
So I ducked behind the Rhino House, go behind the scenes here,
like go in the back door.
And where I finally end up is this kind of non-descriptive hello, this kitchen.
This is the kitchen. We have a freezer and refrigerator down here.
Don't think about a kitchen being at the zoo, but there's a kitchen here. Yes,
yes there. So I'm sorry, your name again? Was Beverly scooting over screen over?
Yes, Beverly is going over. And this kitchen is actually the reason I came.
This is our freezer. It usually runs about 10 below
the rats. And we actually have rats in about four sizes.
We have large jumbo monsters and then we have packs of 50 Mies packs of 25 mice.
And then these are the fuzzies.
You can probably about 10 days old.
The fuzzies and the pinkies are pretty much newborn.
Here's the basic idea.
You want to get closer to what the animals actually eat in the wild.
So you want to give them some sort of whole animal pull as in like all the first
eyeballs whiskers. So, um, what are things different today?
Because the big fetus tomorrow hooves. Um, yeah,
the Tigers are getting some calves and that's not something that we give out
like all the time. Cabs. Can we look at it? So they take me into the [inaudible]
freezer and
in the corner just so the one,
the floor is this box and it's got a black garbage bag kind of thing in it,
which we open up, you know, and like looking right up at me. It happens to be,
the head part is the baby cab, but that's just the head.
It was like a little baby, little eyelashes,
little ears. It's a baby cow, you know. And I thought,
oh baby cow. And then I thought, oh my God,
tomorrow little children are going to be watching this baby cow be ripped apart
by a giant wild cat. They're wild animals. You know, they,
they live in a captive situation, but they still have those wild instincts.
That's Beth stark. She's the one who brought carcass feeding to the Toledo zoo.
The time we hear, oh, carnivores are meat eaters,
but really they're not just meat eaters, they're flesh eaters.
They eat other animals. And one of the challenges there is is how do we,
how do we provide for the welfare of the animals while at the same time
providing for the needs of our visitors.
So it's about 10 o'clock in the morning and the gates are open now.
So visitors are starting to stream in about 15 minutes or so.
They're going to start the tiger feed.
The tiger feeding was the first feeding of the day.
A big crowd was beginning to gather. Right now the tigers aren't in the pen.
How many people are like maybe 150 people? A lot of little kids.
She wrote the board down and pumps since my wife told me about it.
So we made sure we got her early to check this out.
The carcasses were already out.
The zookeeper comes out with her microphone and tweaks sort of gives a little
enrichment program description of carcass feeding
the animals behavioral needs as well as their psychological needs.
And nobody at this point is listening to the interpretive discussion of this
because as she's doing this, I think I heard a door,
they let the Tigers into the panel. Oh look,
here come the tiger's lodge brand. Look, the big one's coming down.
One of the tires just weeks across the pen and grabs the car.
It's like, you know,
it starts like immediately playing with it and I have never seen in all my years
of blue going, I have never seen a tiger move that fast.
Like at 1.1 of the Tigers was like carrying anyone around by the ear.
You could see like the little cafes and it was dragging it around.
What were people doing? Were they cheering? Were they crying?
There was nobody there that seemed to be disturbed by it really.
Although here was a conversation that I heard many,
many times the children would say, what is that?
What is he eating? And the parent would say, I clip a baby cow eats a baby cow.
And the kid would say, why is he doing that,
honey? The tigers have to eat. Well that's what he eats the food.
And the child said, well I don't eat cow penny.
Yeah you do. And the parent would say,
of course you eat cow at home hamburgers and hamburger.
Do you think a hamburger is made out of cows
and there would just be this shocked look on the kid and I must've heard that
conversation like five times. Ooh, honey.
Now it's food. Like a birds in the beasts kind of moment. Yeah, it really was.
People are just fascinated by it. They appreciate being so close to it.
They'll say, Oh god, that's really gross.
But then moving closer for a better view.
What Beth stark was telling me is that,
you know the whole time that they've been doing this carcass feeding program and
they would interview people afterwards and ask them questions.
We did survey people. How did you feel? What did you think?
And found that more than, and what she found,
98% of them is that the public is pretty much uniformly very positive in what
they saw. Enthusiastic.
One of the questions we've put on the survey is do you want to see more of this
in which animals would you like to see?
And so what did people say just about everybody.
From what I can remember circled every animal we put every just about every
animal, every animal, you know, like, you know, do you wanna see dead rabbits?
Do you want to see dead rats? Do you wanna see dead calves?
Do you want to see dead deers?
And do you want them to see them fed to polar bears, tigers, wolves, you know,
like a Chinese menu, you know, like pick your prey animal, pick your predator.
Do you want to see that? And they're like, yes, yes. We want to see this.
The only complaints where people want rabbits fed at Easter and around Easter,
you know,
parents complaining or worrying that their kid was thinking that the Easter
bunny was being eaten. It just shows you how,
like what the animals eat at the zoo is fraught with sort of human emotions and
ideas about right and wrong. Here's another example. Okay?
So when I was at the tiger pen,
there was this woman who came up and was very interested.
She didn't seem turned off by the idea that they were eating a dead calf, right?
But then she got this very strange look on her face and she said,
I hope that was dead. And I said, well, does it does it manner?
I mean because at some point it died, you know,
does it matter whether it died at the hands of a human or the hands of a tiger?
And it was late in the afternoon and I'm ready to go.
So I turn off my tape recorder and just at that second,
even though she's just expressed sort of relief that the calf was dead when it
was putting the Tigers pen,
she starts to tell this story that was so diametrically opposed to what she had
just expressed that I just had to turn my tape recorder back on and say like,
wait a minute. Wait, can you start at the whole beginning?
So what was happening, what happened?
A squirrel health through the layers on the snow lepers cage,
she and her daughter had been hanging out by the snow leopards pin.
There's this sort of net kind of above the pen and there was this squirrel that
had been walking on the net and it fell down.
[inaudible] is here like dumb into the snow leopards pinch.
And her daughter described the story to me where the snow leopard who'd just
been like kind of hanging out, kind of bored, immediately began to stop.
The squirrel snow was pouncing and the squirrel like started trying to get away.
Her mother said it was like the standout. Oh yes.
The snow leopard was matching all of the moves of the score on c file at a move
from, and like the audience was transfixed. Daughter like could not walk.
She hid when she thought the squirrel was coming down. Yeah. Yeah. She took off.
Her daughter couldn't watch, was hiding her face.
And in the end the squirrel escaped. The Squirrel got away. He was smarter.
And I said to the girl, well how did you feel?
Were you rooting for the Leopard or the Squirrel? Which one? And she said,
I was reading for the snow leopard. Huh? And I said,
but you didn't want to see it eat the squirrel and you,
you didn't want to see that. And she said, well,
I still want to for the snow leopard because I didn't want to see it,
but I still wouldn't want it to see it because it is cool nature.
Yeah, the wild.
I think that,
that the reason they felt comfortable watching that and telling me about it was
because it seemed like an episode that was not between the animals and the
human. It was between the animals. What about you? If you were that little girl,
how would you watch that little scene?
You wash it kind of gleefully or more sheepishly.
You just watch, just happening in front
of you. I mean, that has nothing to do with you.
It's funny. Yeah. You know, she, um,
she never mentioned the possibility of feeding live animals to a predator.
By the way, Nell Boyce is a science reporter for NPR. Thank you. Now,
not those frozen rat sickle things, but, but something that scary, Ethan,
you can buy your people's life.
Feeding is a line which Americans use will not cross.
The only places that do feed out live animals as far as we could find are in
China. Lucky for us. Yeah, I live in Beijing.
That's where reporter Jocelyn Ford lifts just over an hour's bus ride outside of
Beijing. We asked Jocelyn to go visit one of these live feeding parks.
That's what they called the live feeding park.
You just get on a bus and they drive you right into the lion's den and they'll
even sell you chicken. But the chickens are about $4 each.
And the tour people sell them right there on the bus or ride in the bus?
No, by the time you, when I talk to you
[inaudible] so they drive.
If the lion's den and one of the people in the best one with the tourists
decided to buy a chicken, I'm gonna feed the lion.
Everyone's do that side of the class.
The Guy who bought the chicken, he would pick it up,
rested again.
[inaudible]
here come the lions.
And soon we had four or five lions [inaudible] sitting right under our window
looking at us, circling US
[inaudible] window. It looks very intense. I tell you,
they had the most intense look I have ever seen anywhere.
I mean they have these very cold amber eyes.
Hungry eyes will always looks like it's ready to pounce
and
the guy with the chicken just opened the window.
I'm going to drop the chicken out
second. That lion grabbed the chicken and just took his mouth.
It helps me smell. Then I noticed that it's legs were still quivering.
Now it's working away at it sort of rippling it to bits
that would say pilot feathers.
Do they hide it to tell you what's your house, your [inaudible]?
I asked your grandmother who was on the bus,
she was with something like a five year old and I asked her if she thought this
was a healthy thing to have this hurt her,
her grandson watching this cruel event.
[inaudible] said, hey, it'll make him a braver guy
if you don't eat them first, they're gonna use.
And she was just very matter of fact about it. Oh my Mama said that
one woman said, we should teach our kids to love animals,
but at the same time, if you know the big random, it's the smaller animal.
That's the way the world works.
So you should understand this survival of the fittest.
Just your dog went though in socially.
And you should also understand where you fit into it.
If you're weak and you can't, you know, run fast, escape or whatever,
you'll become somebody. And that's the lesson of life
I think. I think in the United States that we've,
we're often so far removed from the ugly part of the food we eat.
We just get squeamish when we see it. Whereas, especially the, the,
the rural people in China, you know, they,
they deal with life and death of animals around them all the time.
And I think we're just closing our eyes to it. Having said that, I, I mean,
personally I feel that it does make for more humane society when you do feel
sorry or compassionate about the animals around you.
And there was no concern at the safari park here.
Nothing of that sort. It was all about fun and games.
Okay. So at the end of the bus ride,
they drop you off at the little little circus like place,
and they had a little fake shooting gallery with all sorts of creepy music.
[inaudible] remember?
And I went, I went and looked under this dirty old tent, thrown up over some,
some metal rods,
and there were rows of cages and tigers pacing back and forth and yellow.
Have you ever heard of a tiger? Ya'll
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
the cage. Just the length of his body. He turned it around, but that's about it.
Oh,
thanks to reporter Justin Ford.
This is Radiolab. I'm chat up.
I'm Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich and we'll continue in a moment.
This is Candace currently calling from her bicycle.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thank you.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich and our topic today on radio lab.
Is Zoos the saddest places on the planet there?
What do I have to do? No, they're not this HEDIS place. So you know, I'm right.
The point, Huh? Look,
despite everything we've said up to now about the true wildness of a zoo animal,
the fact remains,
looking into the eyes of a live animal can be an extraordinarily transformative
experience. And don't ask me [inaudible] ask Alan Rabinowitz. Okay.
I'm Alan Rabinowitz. He's going to be our last stop on the show.
I'm the head of a program that seeks to explore the earth's last great wild
areas and try to protect them, right?
Alan Rabinowitz is right noun animal conservation is he set up wildlife
preserves all over the world. And Jed, like you,
he's not particularly thrilled by zoos, although without a zoo.
And I'm thinking of the Bronx Zoo in particular,
he wouldn't be who he is today because when Alan was very young and Archie very
young, he had a terrible stutter.
Oh, I couldn't talk, but my body would spasm you.
So if you wanted to say coming, mom, is he Cummings?
A hard contact coming is the tongue against the upper palate.
So you couldn't get the word out.
I didn't speak a fluent sentence to another human being until I went to this.
Finally, this clinic when I was a senior in college, a senior in college. Yeah.
I never went on a date. I never kissed a girl other than my mom.
How do you connect to anybody and connect to anybody? I had no friends.
None. That's how I had none.
I had little animals that I would take into the closet with me and I would talk
to them fluently
and that's how it was for Alan from much of his childhood.
The only time he says he could free his tongue to talk was in the dark with his
pets, green turtles,
hamsters and troubles and chameleons, which would all die.
I would talk the way we're talking. Will you?
I could talk fluently to the animals and his father one time overheard him
talking to the dark, but we'll maybe we should take this boy to the zoo,
to the Bronx zoo, to the Bronx Zoo.
He used to bring me to the old great cat house. Horrendous.
You remember that gray cat is classic old concrete floors,
but you'd go in, I mean, talk about unexperienced. You'd walk in and here
Ralph Rari. I mean it sounded incredible. Raw power
and he loved being,
he just loved all those noises of like 20 cats all together,
vocalizing at the same time.
Maybe it was the sound, which appealed to me as a kid that couldn't speak.
And once again in front of the zoo, Katz was with, he was alone. You can talk.
Yes, father. It's funny cause he knew,
I talked to the animals so he would stand back.
He knew if he came to clothes I'd stopped because I would stutter because he was
there. But if he wasn't, you could talk more fluently. I could talk fluently.
And there was one, one old Jaguar
and I remember as a kid I would stand there and I would watch that.
I'd watch this magnificent, huge, strong beast.
This massive, strong animal had blank eyes.
It just looked [inaudible]
blank. And it was pacing back and forth and back and forth.
I felt the Sanamal was like me cause I felt strong. I felt good.
I felt powerful inside,
but yet I was trapped inside this cage of my buddy
and that's when Allen remembers turning to that cat as a kind of fellow exile
and whispering a promise that I would try to find a place for us.
I remember that. I remember saying once,
I'll find a place for us. No, I didn't mean that particular.
I don't know what I mean.
I can't really look back and know exactly what I meant, but I,
I felt no matter what I would find a place for us.
Okay.
And that program, I would find a place for us.
He kept that promise in his head for for two decades he went on to visit a
speech therapist.
He learned how to use his mouth and tongue to get past his stutter,
not completely,
but enough to finish college and then to go to graduate school and Study
Wildlife Ecology and it was at his graduation party from graduate school.
We got the offer that would change his life at my going away party.
My major professor asked me if I wanted to go to beliefs and do and study
jaguars. Not just studied them,
count in an objective survey of how many Jaguars are really in the country.
Alan asked, how do you count Jaguars and that's when the professors said, well,
you got to catch them. Catch a Jaguar. How do I know? I have no idea.
It's like saying, go catch a dragon.
Everybody knew the Jaguars are still the almost ghostlike cats in a forest.
Nobody had ever captured Jaguars in the range fires.
That was exactly what the professor was proposing.
Go to a little country in Central America.
Please go deep into its jungle collar,
as many jaguars as you can so that we can track them
and learn about them.
Weeks passed and picture Alan on the edge of the jungle in beliefs.
We had absolutely no idea what to do next. We opened the map of beliefs.
It had one dirt road down the entire country.
Allan figures the only way he's going to catch a Jag.
What do I do this just to talk to people who hunt. Jaguars. Oh, they're there.
They're a, he calls the Mayans and they live in the forest
and I went to the, to the hunters and they told me,
run them with dogs and one hunter still had Jaguar dogs.
And I'll tell you of everything I've ever done in my life,
I still ranked that as the absolute hardest because when these dogs get on a
Jaguar scent, it's a blood [inaudible].
You're running full speed through the jungle.
The Mayans are in front of us running and chopping at the same time.
And I knew in my mind that they would poison the snakes,
but you can't think about it because you don't have time to look where you're
running or get beat.
And one time dashing behind dogs and machete waving hunters, disaster struck.
It would just about actually treated you or when one of the crew got bit by a
poisonous snake
and he died. So everybody quit. Nobody had worked for me.
They all thought I was jinxed.
So then I had to figure out how to capture Jaguars by myself.
Nobody works with me.
Finally one Mayan Indian came to work for me and we ended up building traps and
I would put live pigs because they didn't want dead meat.
They would want live meat, which they could kill themselves.
So I put live pigs in the back of these traps.
I'd have to go feed the pigs every single day. The first trap I built,
I built it out of two by fours.
I caught a Jaguar and the Jaguar chewed its way through the two by four door and
busted its way out of the two by fours,
I mean they are powerful animals and then I built ion rebar.
Even then I made a mistake.
One Jaguar got so mad it bit the iron rebar and pulled at the iron rebar and
snapped its canines.
It snapped its own canines trying to bust the iron rebar.
I mean its roots were hanging out and I put it down.
I tried to do preventive dentistry,
I had to cut the roots and it was lying there dying and I just felt so bad.
I carried the Jaguar back to my cabin.
I lay next to it and it died on the floor next to me. I just lost it.
I lost it.
But one good thing came out of this experience.
He learned to build a better trap. And so cat by cat, my cat,
Allen was able, and he was the first to do this.
He was able to count the Jaguars in that forest and there were thousands of
them, but he had the sense, and again this was,
he was first that they were in real danger because around them people were
cutting down their forest. Then if the forest wind, the Jaguars go too.
So that's when he, uh,
the campaign, she eventually let him do the prime minister.
I was given a chance and not only did the,
did the prime minister agree to meet me, but he,
he invited me to address him in the whole cabinet, but only 15 minutes.
Now remember,
this is a guy who for two whole decades could barely speak his stutter,
which is now less of a problem,
was still there and now he's being asked to address a prime minister and a
capita in a high pressure. Make it or break it 15 minutes or bust situation.
I knew I couldn't stutter. I mean I only had 15 minutes. I said, look,
you will lose nothing by this. If you don't protect it,
guaranteed it's going to be gone because the citrus people want it for both
timber and citrus. Make it a forest reserve and make it tentative.
Make it a five year agreement. If I can't prove to you, I can bring in far,
bring in outside money in five years, what do you have to lose? And if it works,
you've got a Jaguar preserve. You have the world's first Jaguar preserve.
Now his pitch was supposed to last 15 minutes. That's the time he was allotted,
but he went way over.
I ended up staying in there an hour and a half and the vote was a tie in the
cabinet.
The prime minister himself broke the tie in Alan's favorite and by the end he
agreed to the prime minister voted in my favor. That made it.
It got great press as the world's first Jaguar preserve. To this day,
it's the world's only area designated specifically as a Jaguar
prison. And by the way,
the whole time with the prime minister and all that whole time,
he never started
[inaudible].
So Alan decided his work was more or less done.
He could go home now to New York and just before he left he decided to go for
one last walk in the jungle. The last visit he wasn't looking for Jaguars,
he wasn't expecting to see one, this was his goodbye.
But when he was looking down at the ground as you walked along,
suddenly he thought, well hello,
because they're on the ground right in front of him was a fresh print of a
Jaguar and pink,
bigger than any I had seen in that area.
And that just got my blood blood going.
So I started following it. You almost never,
never see a Jaguar when you follow its tracks because it knows you're there.
I mean, I was hoping against hope. I'd maybe I'd see the Jaguar,
but actually I didn't think I would,
cause they always knew I was coming and they'd always go away.
And then it started getting dye started getting late and I didn't want to be in
the jungle at night and I'd have a flashlight or anything.
So that's when I turned around and there was the Jaguar about 15 feet away
behind you. It was behind me, been behind me, probably quite a ways.
So it knew that you were tracking it and it decided to find out who you were and
it circled around and it probably cut off into the forest.
Watch me as I passed,
then got back on the trail and just stayed back a good ways.
And it was pretty clear this cat had been creeping closer and closer.
It's where by the time I turned around and shortened the distance between us,
really small. I mean that was, so, it was in, in leaping distance,
I couldn't have gotten away from it. Yeah. And I knew that.
So I did what I thought was the right thing,
which is make myself small,
make myself subdominant just crouched down.
And then the Jaguar did something, which I didn't expect it to do.
[inaudible]
sat down. That was strange to me.
Okay.
And then I got scared and I stood up.
Then I stepped back because I felt the distance was too close now that that it
didn't like and all this time, I mean I'm totally aware, I have no place to go
and with no place to go, nowhere to run.
Alan just stood there frozen in place and the Jaguar Rosen hit to just stood
absolutely silent.
Then it just turned, started walking off into the jungle
and before it disappeared into the rush,
it turned back to look at me
[inaudible].
Then I really looked at any in the eyes and they were wild eyes.
There was fire in the Jaguar's eyes.
The last thing I remember very clearly is looking into into its eyes and
thinking of seeing that Jaguar in the Bronx Zoo as a child,
but seeing the wildness in this animal's eyes.
It didn't look anything like that cat and the cage.
It showed strength and freedom and we had just protected this incredible area,
which now would be its home.
And I remember telling the cat at one point that I'd find a place for us.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Dr Alan Rabinowitz is the director for science and exploration at the Wildlife
Conservation Society,
and if you want to be more about his Jaguar Adventures and beliefs,
the book is called Jaguar.
One man struggled to establish the world's first Jaguar preserve.
We should wrap up for more information on anything that you heard today.
Check our website, radiolab.org got a podcast we do.
You can sign up for it there or at iTunes and send us an email and let us know
what you think. Radio lab@wnyc.org is the address. Oh,
Radiolab is one word. It is. I'm Chad.
I'm Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich and we'll see ya
at the zoo. It was, he was a zoo. At least some of us.